failure must be an option if failure is
not an option it's going to result in
extremely conservative choices
and you may not may get something even
worse than
lack of innovation things may go
backwards the thing that
you're likely to be world class at is
whatever you
obsessed over from say age 12 to 18.
as an entrepreneur don't learn from
other people how they succeed
learn from how these people fail want to
be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from
the top enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one accept failures with elon musk
when trying different things you've got
to have some acceptance of failure
as you're alluding to earlier failure
must be an option if failure is not an
option it's going to result in extremely
conservative choices
and you may not may get something even
worse than
lack of innovation things may go
backwards
so if what you really want is
[Applause]
risk risk to you you want reward and
punishment
to be proportionate to the actions that
you seek
so if uh if what you're seeking is
innovation
then you should reward success and
innovation
and only
there should be minor consequences for
lack of
minor consequences for for trying and
failing
should that should be minor um
significant rewards for trying and
succeeding
consequences for trying and not
succeeding
and big and major negative consequences
for not
trying rule number two have emotional
stability with warren buffett
well i was lucky that i got started
early i mean it always helps if you get
started early and
and my dad happened to be in an
investment business so i would go down
his office on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a 15-year jump on many people
in
in a sense and that that helped a lot
and and i was always fascinated by them
i knew what i wanted to do early and i
think that's a
that's a huge advantage too and then you
don't need
you don't need a lot of brains in this
business i mean i've always said if
you've got an iq of 160 give away 30
points to somebody else because you
don't need it in investments what you do
need is emotional stability
you have to you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be
you have to be when you come to a
conclusion you have to really not care
what other people say and
and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's
that's tough for a lot of people but
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way
in terms of emotions it's a truism that
investing emotions are your enemy
absolutely that uh when the market's
good if you feel good don't if you feel
bad you should probably do it
right but uh how uh how how did you
uh what was that extra thing where uh so
many will
acknowledge that and yet we saw in the
current crisis
they they panicked why you went into
seemingly uh potential disasters like ge
and
goldman sachs i can't really tell you
the
i mean i didn't learn in school or
anything i just it never bothered me
if people disagreed with what i thought
uh as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about i just stay away
from those
so i stay within what i call my circle
of competence you know
that and tom watson said it best he said
you know he said he said i'm no genius
but i'm smart in spots and i stay around
those spots well
i try and stay around those spots and i
i just don't have a
a problem if if somebody says you know
you're wrong on something i just i
go back and look at the facts and and
i think that i think that really is much
more important frankly than having a few
points of iq
or or having an extra course or two in
in school or anything of the sort you
need emotional stability
rule number three solve problems with
bill gates
my question to you is if you suddenly
found yourself to be say a sophomore in
college
at harvard what do you think you would
study and how do you think you'd
spend your time engaging activities
well the thing that you're likely to be
world class at
is whatever you obsessed over from say
age 12
to 18. you know in my case it was
writing software
uh where i would think i was good and
then i would meet somebody who would
tell me i wasn't
and i would look at their code and i
went through
four sort of comeuppances of oh that's
what a really good programmer looks like
and part of the reason i worship digital
equipment was eventually it was a couple
of their very best programmers
who came and shared with me how they
thought about how they did things and i
had studied their code and
uh and that and there were several
people
who were so key to my doing that so
today
i would go into you know software which
today that means going into artificial
intelligence
uh you know computers still can't read
they they cannot take a book of
information
and say pass an ap test on that book
and that's a solvable problem but it's a
knowledge representation problem
and you know i've always wanted to solve
that problem uh i'm jealous
that maybe one of you gets to work on
that
i'm you know unlikely to go back and be
hands on in that
in that way but it's the juiciest
problem ever i've thought about it for a
long time
uh so i i would go into ai also if you
want to have unstoppable confidence self
love and learn from billionaires check
out my 254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below if you have a great product lots
of people will buy it
and then the company will be successful
investing in yourself is the best thing
you can do anything that improves your
own talents like nobody can take it away
from me they can
run up huge deficits and the dollar can
become worth far less
you can have all kinds of things happen
i've always been passionate
some people thought you know it's more
ocd than anything else
rule number four learn from mistakes
with jack ma
the future has no experts
right we entrepreneurs
someday we are the experts
right so this is what i think and
when you
when an entrepreneur get used to
failure today say alibaba you
succeed well our company won't last 102
years
why 102 years because every
target every goal we give to our team
should be very accurate
we were born in 1999 last century we had
one year we want to spend 100 years and
plus one year one or two across three
centuries
so very accurate we never see we are
successful because we are only
19 years old there is 83 years to go
so we will never see we are successful
we just survived
19 years we are lucky but
in the past 19 years we have made
thousands of mistakes
as entrepreneurs don't learn from other
people how they succeed
learn from how these people fail
because a lot of mba schools they teach
you success
successful case studies when you read
too many successful you think you can be
successful
no
there are a lot of things that you don't
know
because you know some business school
came to alibaba write
case studies they say i know this is
alibaba
and i said no this is not alibaba they
wanted me to sign after one
week study they say this is case study
alibaba ace no this is not me
they say jack you don't know you
[Music]
and i said all right i sighed and
next to five years every year there is a
case study
in qinghua university i was invited
sitting at the back listen to the mba
schools
talk learning about our case study and
they always put a competitor
competitor in alibaba who will succeed
for five years
all they always agree alibaba will die
the competitor will win but five years
all the competitors died
so how can you learn from the case study
like that
learn from the mistakes because the
mistake most of the companies i
i talk to entrepreneurs most of the
mistakes they
made are the same most of the success
reasons you don't know the different
reasons so
when you learn from the mistakes not
because you want to avoid the mistakes
because
when you see the mistakes when you have
this kind of problems
you know how to face it an entrepreneur
have a strong heart towards
the difficulties mistakes the troubles
the failures
but should it be a warm and soft heart
to your colleagues
and to the customers rule number five
establish meaningful connections with
oprah winfrey
you can't get what you want by focusing
on what you don't want
this is about the need to establish
as many meaningful connections as we can
if we're going to save the world we have
to find a way
to connect to each other to connect to
the nature that we're killing
to animals to history to an
acknowledgement
of the lingering trauma of racism and
sexism
we need to connect to the people we love
and mean
something to us and more than that to
the people who don't
that doesn't mean we always have to
agree with another person's philosophy
it means we if we're going to continue
to survive and thrive on this planet
have to find ways to transcend
the politics of division and embrace the
places that
bond us where we find our human ground
rule number six focus on your customers
with jeff bezos
when you buy over internet amazon do you
ever
get the wrong order is anything ever
wrong what do you do do you call up and
complain or you don't have any problems
no i
i i i'm a customer of amazon hopefully
like all of you in this is there one
person full time there's services your
account
even this room is not an amazon customer
see me right afterwards and i'll i'll
walk you through it it's um
i i yeah i get i have problems sometimes
um and i
and i treat them like the same way i
treat a problem that i would get from
customer my email address is famous
and i keep it and i read it it's jeff at
amazon.com i don't see every email that
i get anymore because i get too many
but i see a lot of them and i use my
curiosity
to pick out certain emails i'll get one
from a customer and
there's a defect you know we've done
something wrong that's the usually
people are writing us not always but
usually they're writing us because we've
screwed up their order somehow
and i am so i look at this and for some
reason
something seems a little odd about that
one and so i'll ask the team to do a
case study
and and find real root cause or causes
it's usually causes
real root causes and then real root
fixes
so that when you fix it you're not
fixing it for that one customer you're
fixing it for every customer
and that process is a gigantic part of
what we do
so i would treat my if i have a failed
order or some bad customer experience i
would treat it just like that
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is hustle with mark cuban i started my
first business when i was 12 i was
buying and selling baseball cards buying
and selling stamps
anything i could do to make money i was
hustling and trying to do so
i was in the business but i not so much
where it was
all my friends were into it with me so
they wouldn't know
baseball cards yeah baseball cards you
name it i mean i grew up in pittsburgh
and so i would probably even less than
12 years old i would
excuse me go up buy a bunch of baseball
cards that i collected and i would
package i would say okay you're
guaranteed to have a pittsburgh pirate
in this package and i would charge three
times as much and i'd set up on this
park bench down in the park down in
scott township where i grew up
and um i'd have these little sales and
it was great i made money and i mean it
was
you know and i learned as much about
business when i was 9 10 and 12 as i i
learned any other time
now i've got a really special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and write down in the comments below
when you're going to take
action on that takeaway this week when
you schedule in
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action
you have a 91 chance of actually
following through
compared to just 35 if you just got
motivated
but never created a plan and when you
share your plan and have accountability
you give yourself an even higher chance
of following through so in the comments
below
write down your single biggest takeaway
as well as your specific
plan of action because i want to
celebrate with you
what keeps you so unbelievably grounded
amid all your resounding success
i i feel like success just makes you
more of who you already were
i feel like money and success just does
that so
it's like it holds a magnifying glass up
to who you are
people you know people always ask me
that and i'm like i don't know who else
to be i mean i am who i am
so the money the success and um
so i like to say if you were a jerk
before you got really successful
and a lot of money you you become a
bigger jerk usually and if you were
insecure you'll become more insecure if
you were nice you'd become nicer if you
were generous you'll become more
generous it's
literally just a magnifying glass
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in 30 days check the link right below me
and if you want
more lessons from billionaires check out
the video right here next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe i'll see you soon